hi guys welcome to sketch a so this is
gonna be a special ask IG episode this
is gonna be an ass go J on location with
a field trip or something and it's like
fight it well no it's not actually a
field trip we're gonna go to the set of
lawn order
was in the process of doing my hair
makeup John but uh I found friends here
hi guys what's up what's up how are you
we're great men in black he might be
behind the scenes is Special Victims but
you know welcome to our show
I am so excited all you people out there
that's going on the net this will be on
the Internet these mr. Belzer on Twitter
and I'm final level on twitter october 6
my new novel comes out i am not
associate plug plug plug plug peace you
guys i'm sitting in
Cragen's office right now i'm singing it
in a bathrobe here's one little little
interrogation offices look at look
what's up there but you guys never see
this in the show huh i never i am
noticing it desk hat can I put that out
on
so since wine rescue has been going on
for about 10 years I can't even imagine
how much clothes they have can you show
us the Wardrobe so here in wardrobe this
is absolutely insane like look at all
these clothes so these are all of the
outfits that they're gonna be wearing
those he's going to be wearing this
shirt oh my goodness one of the coolest
things that I found is when you watch a
television show you think that they're
going to all of these different crazy
locations most likely all of those
different locations are all in one
building
Wow trickery I think they go different
places but the domes
there's an entire unedited video tour of
the SVU set on my other iJustine
channels when you're done watching this
video go check it out cuz it's pretty
awesome there's a huge camera in their
face okay
Souths streaming now so the best part
about yes when you said okay so Justine
I click a video baby fusses her in the
bathroom and you're in jail so when are
you gonna shoot was backflip because
he's crazy I select on it and you
haven't even shown the app assistance
and this is just not right that is just
YouTube click fraud Oh
thankfully they forgot to close the door
so a lot of you guys have been asking
when this episode airs I'm actually 100%
sure one and Aires but it's episode
number eight and it's titled users so be
sure to follow me on Twitter and I'll
let you guys know when it airs I hope
you guys enjoyed the special edition of
ask IJ on location it was a lot of fun
having so much fun on the set it's been
amazing so for now and make sure you
guys keep asking those questions on
Twitter on YouTube and as video
responses and make sure you subscribe to
both of my YouTube channels iJustine and
other edges teen and let me tell you
there's gonna be tons of videos on my
other channel all kinds of fun
behind-the-scenes stuff and whatever
else I happen to get myself into here in
New York so I thank you again for
watching I love you and I will see you
the next time I post a video bye
what about me don't I get a header for
ask me did you break into this episode
yeah thanks alter justine ego